I wanted to go back to something you
said about being adverse to learning
something new and just giving something
a try I think you'd written we're just
doing research last night I was maybe on
the super mentors or marks the Kree calm
it was about learn something new I think
that was the title of the post maybe I'm
paraphrasing true but especially for
people maybe Generation X or older they
don't want to learn something new but
Millennials I think are much more open
to it because they've been exposed to
you know all of this technology what do
you say to that to someone that is very
set in their ways about working in a
certain medium and and it holds them
back in some ways what is the question
about the first question always is what
do you want to accomplish and the second
question is am i succeeding at that if
you're not succeeding then you have to
change what you're doing if you're
committed to reaching the finish line
most people stay stuck in the real
question is what is the operational
phrase of your life for many people the
operational phrase of their life is I'm
not getting what I want well if that's
the if that's the sentence that's rule
in your life you've got to find another
sentence and so it's much more
liberating if the sentence is I'm going
to get to the finish line and I'm going
to learn what I need to learn I'm going
to find what I need to find i'm going to
team up with whom i need to team up with
i'm going to create what I need to
create so that's liberating and so for
but also you have to say let me try
something if it doesn't work i'll try
something else a lot of people are very
afraid of failing and you know it's very
funny because you know Lena Lena often
talk about well you know if you sell
down in real life would you just stay
down no you get up to continue on so
good stuff so but a lot of people feel
that if they fail that's the end of it
the doom will ensue and that's not what
happens and so and then it's another
thing that I've always find very funny
is when people say well life is like a
river and it'll take you where you're
meant to go and I always say to them if
you fell into a real River would you
have that opinion and if I know you'd
swim like hell to get to the shore life
is not like a river life is basically
deciding what you want to accomplish
life is not you it's very rarely very
rarely that you're handed something on a
plate what's like here this will be easy
almost everything we try to do is hard
it's difficult but the more will
say well i'm getting i'm going to get
where I'm going you know that's that's
what happens but it's more than what you
want to accomplish i think that there's
a very poisonous thing that we get 12
from china we were small which is that
it's enough to not be happy you know we
don't think that if you're not happy
that it's enough your happiness is
something that we deserve that we all
deserve and to say that well i'm living
in okay life I don't think that's okay
he doesn't think that's okay it's like
know if you're not feeling happy if
you're not feeling like you're doing
your best I really believe that all of
us were born with gifts that belong to
the world and if we're too afraid to
deliver them well that's just a loss
that's just sad and I think a lot of is
going to actually enthusiasm and feeling
happy and giving that original piece
that we're all born with yeah well a few
years ago I had to figure out the secret
of life I was going to be talking to an
audience of at a high school there's
going to be parents and teenagers their
teenage kids and their younger kids and
I said what do I want to talk about and
I thought I just don't want to tell you
no war stories from working in Hollywood
so I thought well maybe I maybe the
useful I told them the secret of life so
I'd to figure out what that was and
having simple so that even little kids
could understand it so what I said
blocks as I said as near as I can figure
the secret of life is be happy be kind
be brave that's it and sometimes you
can't be all three at once but it's
important to strive for those three
things and I think that will that will
lead to a meaningful life and a life
worth living and and also the other
thing is that you know it's very easy to
have an initial enthusiasm for a
creative project but it's very hard when
things start to become difficult when
you have to be there for the long haul
it's also particularly difficulties you
don't know if you're going to succeed so
often you're in the darkness and that's
where you need to surround yourself with
other people who have faith when you
falter years ago when I graduated from
UCLA as an art major by the time I got
out of UCLA knew what I wanted to be a
writer rather than visual artists even
though I had art gallery shows of my
work my paintings in my photography one
when I was a teenager I knew I wanted to
be a writer I wanted
writer producer in TV and there were no
classes on how to do that so I decided I
will write a book about the twilight
zone TV show to learn how to do that job
so I started writing the twilight zone
companion and we started submitting it
as a project publishers and for a two
year period it was rejected it was
rejected by 25 publishers and had it
just been me I would have given up but a
lane said keep going keep going and we
figured out what why it wasn't selling
we fired the agent we had wooden rod
serling's literary agent and we got
another agent she submitted it back to
one of the publishers would have
rejected it to a different editor and
the book sold and the book was an
instant bestseller when it came out it
sold over half a million copies who
still imprinted all these years later
but if I hadn't had a Lane in my life
who believed in me even when i faltered
the book I wouldn't have finished the
book someone else would have come out
with a book on the twilight zone and I
would just spin to life list my life and
bars being bitter yes so so so again
which would have been odd because he
doesn't drink yeah really I would have
just believed those peanuts and drinking
like diet soda or something you would
have been really wasted lives but again
it's very important to surround yourself
with people who love you and people who
believe in you and it's a two-way street
so Lane will falter and and have that
new dark days and I'll say no no let's
let's keep on this path so it's a
two-way street and that's really
important
you